And human beings,
our principal made in the image of that
logos and that's why we can speak things
into being and we do,
and when you speak truth,
then you speak paradise into being and
when you speak falsely,
you speak.
Helen's being and that's the truth,
and what that means is that with every
decision that you make,
you decide for yourself and for everyone
else,
whether you're going to tilt the world a
little bit more towards hell or a little
bit more towards heaven,
and that's the burden you bear for your
existence and the choices that you make
as you pass through life.
And it's the fleeing from that.
That's at the bottom of the nihilism of
postmodernism and the escaped into the
totalitarian certainties of idol
worship.
And none of this is fictional because
we've seen the consequences.
Jonathan said quoting,
I don't remember the source,
that there could be no poetry after
Auschwitz,
but that's wrong,
but the poetry has to be about
Auschwitz.
The lesson for Marsh,
which was never again and fair enough,
but
you.
You can't
decide not to repeat something terrible
unless you understand it,
and the way to understand it is that the
smallest things of each individual
culminate in a great sense of the state,
and so when you ask why terrible things
happened in the world,
the answer is quite simple.
The answer is because you're not good
enough and it's because you don't tell
the truth
and you know it.
Jonathan said something I thought was
very interesting.
It's something I've thought about,
but I haven't talked to him about it at
all.
What happens as you move towards the
truth and the answer is everything comes
together.
It really,
really is.
The answer is everything comes together.
There's even a sexual element to that
because of course,
the highest element of sexual ecstasy is
to come together and around someone
who's telling the truth.
Everything comes together and that's the
potential guests.
One of the world.
It's something that you can partake in.
It's the calls.
It's the call to the greatest adventure
that there is.
You can bring forth something akin to
paradise by speaking the truth and you
can start in your own life and you can
start in,
in,
in the life of your own families,
and these are people in principle that
you love and so why would you do
anything to speak the truth to them,
to protect them from reality?
There's no protecting from reality.
Reality just is you interact with it on
your terms.
Can you do that?
My face get forthright and you do that
by not shying away from the challenge.
I spent a lot of time trying to
understand the sermon on the mount.
It's a very strange document.
I'm going to tell you what I think it
means.
It means conceptualize the highest good
that you town and so you might think
that would be the highest good for you
and it would be the highest good for the
family around you that you love and it
would be the highest good that sound
like in the state and it would be the
highest good for the state in the world
and that would be the highest possible.
Good.
Even though even though you don't know
how to that,
make that what you want and then tell
the truth and it's an adventure because
you don't know what's going to happen.
You have no idea because if you treat
things instrumental,
if you treat people instrumental,
you use them as tools for your own
desire and not.
The problem with that is what do you
know about what you designed?
Many things that you chase will turn out
to be empty.
Well,
what happens if you just tell the truth?
the world will unfold around you in very
strange and mysterious ways and there
isn't anything that's more exciting to
now and it's perhaps something excited
me enough so that suffering that's
attendant on being would redeem itself.
Why that adventure,
and that's the call,
that's the western call to the
individual,
is suffering of being can redeem itself
through truth and it's not.
It's,
it's not a rule.
It's not a proposition that you need to
adhere to like a good citizen.
It's,
it's the proper way of winning your way
through the terrible world without
making it worse than it already is.
But the possibility perhaps of making it
better,
there's no more exciting possibility to
not a no higher moral demand.
The thing is is everyone knows that you
know when you lie according to your own
conception of the truth,
that there is some sheet,
something shameful and demeaning about
that and know that it hurts people and
you think,
well,
why do you do it despite all of that,
in part because it's easy and partly the
you do it because there's a crooked,
horrible,
hellish part of your soul that's more
than happy if part of what you do is
make everything worse.
The page for the sin of its existence.